visual studio code is like a knife it's
only as good as the hands that wield it
but unfortunately it has more knobs than
a fighter jet and requires the steady
hand of a surgeon to the untrained eye
vs code is just a simple text editor
like microsoft word with code
highlighting
but in reality it contains a ton of
productivity boosting features that
you're probably not using yet
in today's video we'll compare amateur
vs code techniques to the ones used by
professionals allowing you to write and
analyze your code faster
because the most valuable thing you own
in this world is your time if you're new
here like and subscribe then leave your
best vs code pro tip in the comments
i'll choose one of them to win this free
t-shirt next week and now let's jump
right into things by installing vs code
once installed you'll want to open up a
directory with some files in it maybe
you just generated a new astro project
from the command line
then to open it in your editor you pull
up the file explorer and click
open with vs code that works but it
would have been much quicker had you
done it from the command line if you're
in the terminal and want to open a
directory or edit a file you can do that
quickly with the vs code cli
using the code command but keep in mind
if you're on mac or linux you need to
first add the binary to your path
now that we have the editor opened it's
tempting to go around two different
windows with the mouse and click on
buttons to run commands just like we
would with any other software
but here's a little productivity secret
the less you rely on the mouse the
better
vs code allows you to use the mouse for
everything making the tool approachable
but that's really the most efficient way
to get things done you don't have to go
crazy and learn something like vim or
emax
but it's important to understand that
anything you do with your mouse can
likely be done quicker with the keyboard
virtually every command you see in the
vs code window can be done with a
keyboard shortcut you don't need to
memorize them all but knowing about 10
to 20 will literally change your life
letting go of the mouse may not feel
natural at first but mastering the
keyboard is a lot like learning to play
an instrument
it takes a lot of practice but
eventually it becomes second nature the
first shortcut you'll want to memorize
is control papa
which brings up the command palette the
beauty of the command palette is that it
gives you all the power of vs code from
the keyboard without having to memorize
a bunch of key bindings
by default it will give you a list of
recently opened files
in addition you can start typing a file
name to find it in your project and
that's obviously much quicker than
trying to find a file by clicking
through a bunch of directories in the
file explorer
but the command palette can do a lot
more if you type a right angle bracket
it will give you access to virtually any
command that you can run in vs code
along with the commands for the
extensions that you use
for example you may want to toggle the
minimap or one thing that you'll notice
in some of my videos is that i execute
javascript directly in the file itself
and that's made possible by an extension
called quoca which is a tool that i can
start and stop in any file via the
command palette the extension itself is
really cool
it automatically runs your javascript
code in the background then appends the
output directly in your editor which can
facilitate rapid prototyping when your
goal is to just write some plain
javascript code
now another really awesome thing we can
do here is find pieces of code or
symbols throughout our project when
working in a really big file it's easy
to get lost
the worst thing you can do is scroll
around the page looking for the function
or
interface that you need you could do
control foxtrot to find that text on the
page
but an even better approach is to use
the at symbol from the command palette
that'll list out every symbol in the
code so you can quickly navigate to it
and if you want you can bypass the
command palette altogether by entering
ctrl shift period to do the same thing
directly in the file itself now in other
cases you may want to find a symbol
throughout the entire project
including all of your dependencies like
node modules use a hashtag
followed by the name of the symbol
you're looking for to find that
interface in your own code or your
dependencies code
another really awesome bonus tip here is
that if you have a really long class
name you don't even have to type the
whole thing out
just the first character in each camel
cased word and it will work just as well
the command palette is awesome but it
doesn't really help you write your code
faster when you see a line of code that
you want to edit
the natural approach is to take the
mouse and then highlight that line
a developer might do this hundreds if
not thousands of times per day
a faster way to get to where you need to
go is to hit control golf
followed by the line number that you
want to focus on from there use the
arrow keys to go character by character
and hold down the shift key if you want
to highlight something or use ctrl arrow
to move word by word
when your cursor lands on a word that
you want to edit hit ctrl
delta to highlight it so you can then
delete it or replace it
but here's where things get really mind
blowing if those characters appear
multiple times in the code and you want
to edit them all at the same
time just hit ctrl d again and again and
you're now a 3x developer editing three
lines of code at the same time
in some cases you may want to use the
mouse for multi-line editing
holding down alt while you click on
different parts of the editor will set
up cursors in multiple
places that can be really useful for
writing repetitive css properties
one place you might use this often is
with opening and closing html tags
but you can actually make your life even
easier by installing the auto rename tag
extension
this will automatically rename the
closing tag when you edit the opening
tag and it can work in other languages
beyond just html
now in other cases you may just want to
delete or move a line
the amateur approach is to highlight
that line do a right click with the
mouse and find cut then do another right
click with the mouse and find paste
here's the faster approach if your
cursor is already on a line all you have
to do is hit ctrl x to cut it no
highlighting is necessary
but if your goal is to move the line
somewhere else then there's an even
better approach
use alt followed by the up or down
arrows to move the line somewhere else
quickly
and if you want to copy that line as you
move it use alt shift followed by the
arrows
now one other thing that you likely
often do in your code is comment it out
to disable it the worst possible thing
you can do
is go line by line adding the comment
syntax to each line
if this is how you currently do comments
you'll want to pay attention to this
next shortcut
first highlight the code using your
mouse or by using the control
l command to highlight line by line once
highlighted use ctrl forward slash to
toggle comments on that code now when
speaking of code comments
it's often important to format them
properly in javascript that typically
means following the js docs standard
and there's an extension called add
js.com once installed
it allows us to highlight a function
then use the command palette to add a
comment to it automatically
bonus tip in your js dot comments you
can use the link tag to link to other
symbols in your source code when you
hover over that symbol it will give you
the comment that if you click the link
it will take you to that part of the
code automatically that makes writing
comments much easier but what if we
could also make them easier to read
by also installing the better comment
extension we'll get automatic
highlighting in our comment text
any line that starts with a bang is now
red and all of our to-do's are
highlighted orange
but now let's switch gears into a very
important topic the terminal you can
open a new terminal session directly in
vs code in your current working
directory
using control backtick when you start a
new terminal it uses your default shell
which in my case is bash
if you click the caret you can use a
different shell if needed like
powershell or wsl
what often happens though is you need
multiple terminal sessions running
at the same time like one for your test
runner one for your dev server
and so on to keep things organized click
on the icon
then change the name or the color of
that session and now you don't have to
fumble between different terminals to
figure out what each one is doing
now when you type out an actual command
in the terminal and you screw it up you
can use ctrl arrows to quickly navigate
to a different part of the actual
text because your mouse won't even work
here but if you already hit enter and
got an error message
you can use ctrl k to clear out the
terminal then use the up arrow to go to
the last command in your history
and just rerun it instantly but what if
there is a way where you didn't have to
write the same terminal command over and
over again
like how many times have you written npm
run build or npm run test
to simplify things you can create a vs
code task
which is just a json configuration that
contains a command that you want to run
in the terminal
now instead of pulling up the terminal
and writing out a command you can just
use the command palette to run it
automatically and it will show the name
of that task in the terminal sidebar
here
speaking of the terminal one of the most
common things you'll do here is execute
commands for version control using
get not only are git commands hard to
remember but it can be very dangerous
and painful when you mess them up the
standard procedure for get [ __ ] ups is
to go to stack overflow and look at the
top questions there because they're
almost all related to get
the funny thing though is that i think
this is an area where it actually makes
more sense to use your mouse as opposed
to the keyboard in the source control
tab in vs code we get a breakdown of all
the changes in our current working
directory
we can just point and click at files
that we want to stage and also notice
the icon next to each file which will
tell us if that file has been modified
added or removed now from the drop down
menu we get a list of all the possible
git commands
most often we're just committing files
but vs code will give us a breakdown of
all the possible commands without having
to look them up in the documentation
if you're working on a big complex
project with other developers i'd highly
recommend installing the git lens
extension it provides a bunch of extra
ways to visualize and explore your code
and most importantly it will tell you
exactly who to blame when your code
stops working
it's a really great extension but now
we're going to look at another extension
that's brand new and even crazier
normally when you want to work with a
git repo on github you need to clone it
to your local system but now
thanks to the monopoly that microsoft
has on the developer ecosystem
this process can now be streamlined with
remote repositories
install the extension then click on this
icon in the bottom left corner
to open up a remote repository it'll
have you log in with your github account
then you can start contributing to any
repo on github without needing to worry
about complex git commands you can
create a new branch
edit some code and then submit a pull
request without ever having to leave bs
code in addition to remote repositories
you should also know about remote ssh to
connect to a remote server
and also remote containers to use a
docker container as your development
environment
instead of your local system these
extensions are managed by microsoft and
can turn your basic text editor into a
full-blown integrated development
environment
but let's get back to our actual code in
many projects you may find yourself
writing the same boilerplate code over
and over again
if you find yourself doing that an easy
way to improve your productivity
is to create a custom snippet from the
command palette run the configure user
snippets command
you can create global snippets to use
across all of your projects or scope
them to an individual workspace
basically you just modify this json file
with the code that you want to insert
then when you go back to your main
project you can use the insert snippet
command
to quickly add your own custom
boilerplate but if you work with a
popular framework
there's a good chance that somebody
already did this work for you before you
go building your own
check out the extensions panel to see if
there are any pre-built snippets out
there that already meet your needs
oh and here's a cool random thing if you
need to create a new file in the file
explorer
but it lives in a directory that doesn't
exist yet you can create that file
along with any nested directories on top
of it automatically
by just putting a slash in front of the
file name and vs code will automatically
create those directories
now yet another awesome tool that i want
to mention is the pace json as code
extension
if you work with typescript one
extremely tedious thing you might have
to do
is take a json object and convert it to
a bunch of types to represent some kind
of schema this extension will take your
json and automatically infer types using
a tool called
quick type and in some cases that can
save you hours of work
but the final thing i want to leave you
with is a quote you've probably heard
before
there are only two hard things in
computer science cash invalidation
and naming things naming your code is
hard which means that you'll often be
renaming things
when you name something poorly your
first idea might be to do a find and
replace
across your whole project but that can
be kind of dangerous a better idea is to
find the thing you want to rename
then if you right click it you can find
all of its references or
implementations then from there you can
use the rename symbol option
to safely rename it across all of your
files i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there but make sure to share
your own vsco pro tips in the comments
and if you want to support my work
consider sponsoring me on github or
becoming a pro member at fireship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one